troubling new details about the online
dangers to children who have been
spending more time in front of computers
during the pandemic cbs news has
discovered that the number of calls
about attempts to lure or exploit
children online has surged 35 percent
to one tip line alone in just the past
year our scott mcfarland exclusively
obtained a new review by the national
center for missing and exploited
children and has a warning for all
parents
when she was 13 years old alicia kozak
thought she'd found another teen friend
online lured from her home in pittsburgh
by a man who held her captive for days
eventually triggering a nationwide
manhunt i was taken to virginia and held
captive in his basement dungeon
where i suffered horrendous abuse more
than a decade after being rescued by law
enforcement kozak says predators realize
kids across america now have even wider
access to phones and computers at an
even younger age if a predator were to
try to groom a child at a park or at a
mall or somewhere at school something
like that they really only have those
few chances whereas on the internet they
can just easily close that chat box and
close that up and go to that next
possible victim predators recognized
there was a moment and an opportunity in
a pandemic the predators recognized that
there was going to be more hours online
where teens and children were going to
be unsupervised and they were
encouraging each other to seize upon
that opportunity the non-profit national
center for missing and exploited
children operates a clearinghouse for
tips of child online exploitation in a
new report released to cbs news the
center says it received 29.3 million
reports of suspected child sexual
exploitation last year an increase of 35
from 2020 and an all-time high as for
parents kozak says taking away devices
is not the answer
they have to monitor what their children
are doing online they have to pay
attention and i know it might seem like
you're invading their privacy but you're
not you're keeping them safe
nearly all of the 29 million tips came
from phone and social media companies
which are legally required to report
possible unlawful images to the national
center and noting this shift in the past
year they received more tips about
possible unlawful videos than still
images vlad
an important and disturbing report scott
thank you very much